you uh correct me if i'm wrong you were
on like a kind of like a pop tour or is
that
oh i was uh going around doing shows at
imagine dragons imagine dragons yeah
what was that like i'm a pop star bro
no i'm just saying because an imagine
dragon's concert is like a whole
different world what's a cereal like a
serious level of caucasian that goes to
those shows 100 you know what i mean and
i'm definitely like
the
the minority in the biggest regard you
know what i'm saying so
i [ __ ] with it though they got some
anthems yeah they got like they
literally have stadium music 100 you
heard that [ __ ] in target you heard it
in commercials and commercials
everywhere in the movies and soundtracks
all of that stuff um it's crazy bro it's
just a whole nother level of performing
it teaches you like i'm gonna say that
has to really like you gotta cut your
teeth going into a crowd that's probably
not there for what you're bringing to
the table all arenas
uh but our song is one of the biggest
songs ever you know what i'm saying is
probably i think it was the fastest to
reach
the heights that ever you know i'm
saying i don't know to the heights of me
but that song big as hell so they know
who i am like every time i perform they
just roaring applause it's crazy like
just making sure like even the way i'm
rapping i'm rapping super fast so it's
just like me doing 26 seconds of like
i'm out of there but you know no it
helped me become a better performer i
would say who reached out was it someone
in the group that was just a fan of you
that was like yeah like dan uh reynolds
he's the
lead singer i feel like he was a fan he
he told me that he was and it was done
through the label